good I'm from the Council on the future
of government and we are looking how the
government the future should look and we
have the found some kind of an acronym
we describe the government the future as
a fast government which stands for
flatter agile streamlined and
technologically savvy means it's a
government which is platter in the sense
that it is closer to the citizens less
bureaucratic fewer layers of
responsibility so that it can operate we
make a closer environment to the citizen
agile in a sense that can adapt quickly
to the changing circumstances in a sense
that it can for example utilize social
media utilize new modalities for the
delivery of services streamlined in the
sense that it simplifies these processes
and procedures and obviously
technologically savvy because it can
utilize the advantages of technology
obviously the internet but especially
the social media so this is in a
nutshell what our council has been
developing the overall overarching theme
is that governments are not longer along
in the business of providing public
goods governments have to rely both in
terms of decision-making input for the
filmmaking and in terms of
implementation on other actors of
society and governments who can
establish modalities for such
cooperation are the one who are going to
be working better in the future